no stories in a moment but first a  family was left hiding in a closet as a  serial burglar  walked through their west valley home  last week thank you for joining us at 11  i'm brian loftis and i'm denise feldas  so tonight our i-team was the first to  report the story that will have you  double  checking to make sure you locked your  front door investigators say the crime  spree involving a serial burglary  suspect happened last tuesday  in the lakes neighborhood not too far  from fort apache and desert inn  now documents show one armed homeowner  saw the man walk right  through his home that night and court  records show  27-year-old dalton korshinowski is  facing now six counts of burglary in the  case  investigators say he had stolen items in  his possession  when he was arrested